you work very hard to take care of uh
your dad's legacy i know that's a big
that you do so much work to take care to
preserve his music to make sure that
it's presented properly it's a it's a
labor of love and you know i we made
music together we talked a lot about
stuff and you know this whole thing
which happened you know ten years after
we'd done the dark horse years which was
kind of like our star wars four five and
six and then we had to go back and do
one two and three um
it was you know it's been 14 years i
mean since we're 13 since my dad died
this year and and we've been you know
this has all been in a uh in my head
with dad you know
thinking about it for so long that it's
really great to see it sitting on your
desk and to just have the fun bit which
is going out and playing some music and
this is absolutely fantastic this is a
beautiful piece of work uh
the apple years
you were told me someone told me that uh
that you were skateboarding around town
here in los angeles and interesting
stories yeah what were you doing
skateboarding well i was at the santa
monica courthouse which has recently
been been made into a legal skate spot
because actually i made the stupid
mistake of skating during court hours
there once when i was 12 and i got
detained um as a minor really for hours
yeah by the police because skateboarding
was a crime back then in
1989 um
and
they put my board in the gun crusher
which was unfortunate for my board
anyway so i recently went back there so
what happened you were detained what
came and got you out my aunt i think
drove from palm springs and got me out
yeah so thanks linda um
and uh so here we are in the year 2014
and it's a legal skate spot now and um
we would i was discussing with a friend
of mine a pro skater called richie
jackson we were leaving there the other
day in my car and i said
wow isn't it so great that we can skate
here and not get arrested and just as he
said that it went
and we got pulled over
and um
i discussed with the police officer that
he didn't know i didn't have my id i
said like if you need proof of who i am
i'll be on conan on wednesday and
we're doing this uh george harrison week
and my name's annie harrison nice to
meet you um sorry i didn't make any
mistakes uh driving i was just driving
and um
he walked off and he came back he goes
well i'm a huge conan o'brien fan
um
and uh
you guys you know go along on your
business yes wait a minute i would think
george harrison would yeah no
this guy has his priorities wrong and uh
no no thanks man
[Applause]
tell me more of this george harrison
i'm not having it and he had this big
smile on his face when i said conan
o'brien and let me go which was
you're free to use that in your life at
any time eat it pull a cone and call it
it works uh
i also want to thank you personally i i
mentioned this the other day on the on
the air but i was in london and you had
me over to your home and i'm such a huge
fan of your dads and of his work and you
let me hold his guitars and one of the
just a transformative experience for me
you're just a very generous soul always
a good to thank you man it was a really
good day uh because we were just there
working away uh paul hicks and i
actually paul who remastered these uh
records with me and um
and uh you know we knew you were gonna
be in england so we thought come down
and have a have a nice day because it's
you can't really say oh well it's kind
of like this it's kind of like that you
just know it's absolutely
yeah and when you grab a guitar off the
wall and say look it's the 12-string
rickenbacker from hardy's night catch
and it's like
don't look at it don't look at it